she's the founder of PETA an author of
animal kind remarkable discoveries about
animals and revolutionary new ways to
show them compassion Ingrid Newkirk
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you so much for being here I am
NOT one of those people who uses the
word hero a lot they get asked that in
interviews a lot who your heroes I'm
like oh [ __ ] why'd you have to ask me
that but it easily rolls off my tongue
with you you are one of my heroes there
was no animal rights to be even speaking
of before you came along and PETA is now
is this the 40th anniversary there were
you Leonardo da Vinci preceded me and he
talked about animal rights is that right
and what happened to him but that's just
in the time we have first so we don't
lose it go through some of your greatest
hits where the world was in 1980 with
animals and some of the things you know
the the furs and the testing in the labs
just give me a small be a modest it's
gonna be your greatest hit so but
everybody wanted to fur I mean that's
the way I grew up it's right on your
grandmother's fern you wanted one you
derived if you got one right and nobody
thought that we were anything but mad
when we protested the circus little kids
ran out onto the street that's what they
had there was no internet
experimentation it was little old ladies
and tennis shoes who protested against
it according to the researchers now we
have 19 scientists on staff they're in
all sorts of disciplines they teach the
EPA and the USDA how to changed
non-animal research and we're making
huge strides Ringling Brothers greatest
know Shamu that poor bastard doesn't
have to
jump up and down for fish anymore and
movies didn't that mean like they did
anything to animals when they got him on
camera - you know oh you want to make
mr. ed look like he's talking you know
hit him with this cattle prod or you
know you want the baby chimpanzee yes
that was the big thing no one even knew
they were babies because you can't
control a full-grown chimpanzee so they
would take the babies away from their
mother and they would use pool cues and
electric shock collars it's all gone now
because we push push push and people
still don't have a soft heart for
animals you know one of your great
themes over the years was we're
connected you know I always think of
that when they catch a serial killer
because they almost always find out well
he started torturing animals first and
we see it Australia this this horrible
animal genocide that happened because of
the fires and there and the corona virus
started because people are eating things
they shouldn't be eating into exotic
pets and stuff like that we're all
connected right oh absolutely I mean our
big pushes against speciesism we're you
were talking about isms earlier on
there's another one to throw into the
porridge which is against human
supremacist and was we sometimes think
we're gods we're not gods and animals
aren't trash we should all be in this
together and really consideration
respect understanding non-violence
surely that's something that everybody
can embrace doesn't matter what you look
for it and what's the what's the biggest
what's the biggest challenge left I mean
you you know a lot of victories but you
have a lot of work to do I mean I know
you're always all over the world you're
not just the founder you're still the
person who's out there
I live in can I say shoe leather but
certainly not leather and these are not
leather I think the biggest problem is
that is factory farming well factory
farms that's gonna be huge
yes water houses the transport to
slaughterhouses are terrible but really
things are changing so much you know
when we first used the V word vegan that
people were up in arms about it they
thought that's the stupidest thing we've
ever heard now you basically can't walk
out under the street without seeing
something that says vegan you go to the
supermarket right
we used to mix so we've powder with
water and that's what we had to make a
non-dairy milk now you go to the
supermarket and you spend ten minutes
thinking should I have the oats milk VR
you know what should I do and your book
was fascinating a big is it so a lot
about things I didn't realize I guess a
lot of what I've learned in recent years
from animals is watching videos on
Facebook and YouTube they like each
other more than I thought they did and
that was sort of reinforced by your book
even the ones from different species and
then they have you know empathy that we
didn't used to think they had and they
grieve and and they care about each
other that that that's tell me a little
bit about that and where you have come
with Valentine's Day is coming up and
they their love for each other and for
us is extraordinary
I used mentioned YouTube videos I
wouldn't fault them at all because
they've taught a lot of people how
wonderful animals are in the book I try
to connect all these dots and show
people that it's not a human
characteristic to fall in love to flirt
to kiss they're all these animals in the
world who do the same thing they love
each other and they love us but pigeons
for example are so derided people can't
stand them but the male and the female
pigeon both make milk in their crop and
they both take turns looking after their
baby they're admirable parents and they
could teach human beings a lot
these you must have seen a big change
generation wise I mean you started with
the baby boomers and then you move
through Generation X and now we're on to
the Millennials and Gen Z I mentioned
like with many social movements there
are a lotta than the generations that
came before them I mean the kids they
don't even like pubic hair let alone fur
to pineapple and apple and grape leather
right and they're switching they won't
wear wool
you know we've shown in the sheep
shearing sheds try to say that quickly
the shearers actually smashing the sheep
in the face with the metal shearing
objects standing on their necks twisting
their necks until they actually die
sometimes there's just so much violence
and the kids don't like it the kids are
growing up saying you know you are
parents what were you thinking of and I
believe that as the generations go on
that they are going to look back at us
and say did you really wear animals did
you really take their lives for such
frivolous things did you really not move
quickly to get away from force-feeding
rabbits and putting things in dog's eyes
and so on in the lab what was wrong with
you know it is one of those things we
will look back on yeah and and there are
now what six and a half million PETA
members there are indeed well if you
want to help the way to do it is to join
because what gives you power besides
your amazing force of nature nosov made
so many corporations change their policy
because you can say I have this army
behind me they're not going to buy your
product that's the only thing that moves
the dial in America right the power of
the power of the purse so that's how you
do it
and I just gotta say I remember reading
your saying once that you know social
movements they start with ridicule then
they move to the discussion phase and
then they move to acceptance you are
singularly responsible you made it from
ridicule to discussion and to halfway to
acceptance and I know you're gonna
finish the job thank you so much for
doing what you do
[Applause]
you